yeah we began to look much more into
virtual spaces now the idea being that
people have much more control over those
to try and understand what people are
doing in that context are they using
virtual spaces of by virtual spaces I
mean things like social networking sites
like Facebook and so on how are they
using those are they using those just as
a medium of social communication or are
they using those as a kind of way to
promote themselves to portray themselves
in a positive light
we thought we were very interested about
we are interested in whether people use
their social networks as a kind of
compensation to so is it the people who
are really outgoing can go into this
virtual space to behave like an
introvert or is that just another
opportunity for them to be outgoing so
do we see the the out offline activity
mirrored online or do we see it more of
a hydraulic models they do one on line
one offline and what we found in that is
that people tend to do the same thing so
the people who are extroverted and have
loads of friends in real life have loads
of friends on Facebook to people who
have loads of interests in in the
offline world also also doing the online
so in this in this case people are it
acts is just really an extension of
their everyday life having said that
there's a couple of interesting things
is that is that people don't really know
how they're viewed on the basis of their
spaces so one of the things we've looked
at is is whether people project a
accurate view of themselves or they
project an inflated positive view of
themselves because we thought well maybe
people are using these more like a sort
of a personal website in order to
promote themselves or are they really
just using it as a way of communicating
more like the telephone are they just
using it as another way of living out
their lives and so how we tested that
was we got people to observe people on
the basis of their Facebook profiles and
we compared that to how people really
saw themselves and also how they would
like to be and what we found there was
that people the impressions people get
of you based on your profile and they
know nothing else about you but just
based on your profile match much more
closely with how you really see yourself
than how you'd like to be and that
raises the question of well what are
people trying to create a false
impression and failing or is it that
they're not they're not trying at all I
we don't really know what's going on and
whether they're trying failing or just
not trying but one of the interesting
things which would make it a real
challenge
to create a false impression even if you
wanted to is that people have no idea
how they viewed on the basis of their
profiles so if you give somebody if you
if you say okay what do you think people
think you're like on the basis of your
profile and then you compare that to
what people really think whether those
things are entirely on Carly if they
have people are completely oblivious to
the impressions they portray in everyday
life which of course has all kinds of
implications for for in terms of your
ability to try and control it but also
you have no idea what impressions these
employers who are looking at your
Facebook profiles our or people who are
you know cyber stalking you or whatever
you have an idea what impressions
they're really getting up
well I think there are a number of these
effects which really only show up which
we which are nonlinear so people are
seen as more and more positive if they
have for example a large number of
friends and contacts if they have too
many then it's it then it's seen as it
turned becomes become seen a negative
light so you so you have to control the
number of connections that you have but
I think one of the sort of the broader
point is you have to kind of realize
that you can't really control these
things I mean I think most of the
technologies that we've had you know
probably since industrialization you as
we used to live in tiny groups of people
and we'd know everyone in our group we
and we wouldn't have this idea of having
a work self and a social self and a
relationship self and even you know sub
cells within those would you just be the
person everyone would know you from all
of those contacts when we lived in small
groups then then when you when you start
having a life where you have to leave
and you go to work and you have people
who know your work who don't know your
home you begin to segment these things
up you have these different cells you
have this idea that you can go and be a
professional self and then that's
different and it doesn't matter that
that you behave in what some people
might think as a non-professional way at
home and so and I think until now all of
the technologies have increased the
segmentation they've made us go into
these different fields but now with with
the social networking sites that all
where we can't really control who looks
and we can control a bit but not that
much and when where people can look us
up on Google suddenly you're losing
control of that I think this is the
first technology that's now beginning to
have reversed the trend so you can for
the first time you can now no longer
keep these things separate so I can
dress up in my suit and shirt and go in
and teach my students at the University
and you know portray myself in this very
serious professional way but I can't
stop them you're logging on and finding
photos of me you know drunkenly yelling
at the camera with all of my friends to
is I've lost control of that so I think
you know part of the thing that we have
to do is is sort of
shrug and so reconcile ourselves to this
idea that look we are multifaceted and
people know them we've always been
multifaceted but we've been able to
we've been able to portray ourselves to
direct certain certain cells to certain
audiences we're losing control of them
and I don't know really if there's much
way around it I think norms will change
though I think normed will change I
think people will understand just
because you go out and you know go to
Renaissance Fairs in the weekend that
doesn't mean you can't be a good
accountant or you know they'll realize
the fun in fact those people who have
always seen at Renaissance Fairs they
are the accountant supported